schools are intervening no squid game
costumes this halloweening
but are these administrators mean for
taking the fun out of halloween three
upstate new york elementary schools
aren't they all
abandon squid game costumes citing the
potential violent message aligned with
them as the reason also some of the
children have seafood allergies
principals reportedly sent an email to
parents after noticing that kids were
playing a version of the games on the
playground
of course the parents were the ones that
let the kids watch that stuff now by a
version of i assume they meant that the
kids were not actually killing each
other on the playground that would be
funny and weird according to
superintendent craig tytisse
no items that can be interpreted as
weapons should be brought to school and
that costume should not be too gory or
scary
well i gotta say that covers a lot it
doesn't leave us with many options does
it i mean a you can't be daring
you can't be scary you can't even be
interesting
i guess that leaves us with one option
tyrus got a lot of halloweens to deal
with this week you got four kids
what's your take on the costumes you
know i sometimes i think this is they do
it for marketing yeah because if you
don't mention it yeah
nobody that's not a great costume
[Laughter]
he looks like an out of work mario bad
guy that never got a chance to be on the
turtle team like there's nothing
exciting about a black mask with a
circle but now because the school's
against it and they're coming out again
publicly every high school every 14 to
17 year old in america is like yo i got
to have that like they continue to do
the wrong thing they just don't get it
yeah dracula we had zombies i mean you
name it people would do it yes and when
you don't make a big deal about it
it's not there but now it's a big deal
yeah i
i want to go as a billionaire
i think you already are
i think i'm really how did you change
your outfit right now to go as a
billionaire well you know come as you
are yeah you just switched the mug to
like a gold mug i mean last year i went
as a tax cut this year i want to go as a
billionaire
and i want to talk to these kids you
know you're handing out candy yeah too
much welfarism
you know they've gone to school and
their parent and their teachers have
taught them to be woke socialists yeah
so i you know i can prove them and we
can talk about the virtues of equal
opportunity and capitalism yeah just
break off part of the candy bar and go
that's for the government yeah then
throw it into the street and you have to
take it you can throw it into the street
you have to have work fair yes work fair
are you gonna make oh kids show up at
your house make them do chores yes
okay uh kate what uh what do you make of
this costume
first the only thing i would say is you
could put some hundreds in your instead
of a pocket square that's that could
help your uh billionaire look benjamin
there you go there you go
speaking like a like a billionaire
but um but yeah you know what's so
interesting is i've never heard of this
show or what this game is i am allergic
to shellfish so you know i'd also stay
away from the squid but i again they
they don't trust children to live in a
fantasy world and that's what's so
strange is that it's like the adults are
always the ones
putting mixing fantasy and reality right
and it's like they can't trust that a
kid knows the difference between
dressing up as something scary and can
murder and
do and not murder someone but they can't
do it that's why they're bringing in
tale and harry potter to make analogies
for everyday life right and it's like
you don't get calls that there's a bunch
of feral cats running around new york
city on halloween when a bunch of
middle-aged women are dressed as you
know leopards and all that you know what
i mean like you just like it
it's halloween and we're seeing honestly
more violence on a day-to-day basis with
all these masks that we're forced to
wear you see more violence between just
masking and unmasking than the one day
we're supposed to mask exactly the most
dangerous
is a mask that's it or the unmasked
cat hi
well no speaking of middle-aged women
they're the real victims of this right
because this email went out i think
pretty late what if they already had the
kid's costumes yes this is a war on
women it is a war on women i'm disgusted
me too
i would pick it but i'm lazy and no cash
bail no cash mail
all right up next are men and women
peers when it comes to shed in tears
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else